samedi à 22h sur Public
Sénat Gérard Longuet vice-président de
l'UMP sénateur de la Meuse et l'invité
de preuve par 3 bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous avec Daily
Motion avec l'Agence France Presse
représenté tout à l'heure par notre NAD
puljac et alors que Perin Arnaud comme
chaque semaine de Public Sénat nous
rejoindra pour la dernière partie de
cette émission du non lieu de Nicolas
Sarkozi à l'offensive du Front national
que rien ne semble arrêter de la
situation économique aux réformes et à
votre accusation osé avec plusieurs de
vos collègues UMP au Sénat d'un penchat
actuel vers le collectivisme les sujets
et les questions ne manquent pas Gérard
Longuet d'abord évoquons François
Hollande et Emmanuel Vals qui étit en
visite ce mardi le Pr premier dans la
Loire le second à forbac en Mosel même
motivation lutter contre la colère
contre la désespérance contre la
frustration le sentiment d'abandon et
puis également intensifier la lutte
contre l'insécurité et le chômage mais
on a également appris dans le même temps
l'émorragie des emplois chez Alcatel
Lucent 10000 suppressions nettes de
postes partout dans le monde 900 en
France l'État doit-il peut-il se
contenter de demander un plan social le
moins douloureux possible enfin vous
avez évoqué et beaucoup de sujets voulez
commencer par lequel par Alcatel lucen
bien sûr oui alors Alcatel lucen nous
démontre une fois encore qu'une
entreprise pour rester leader doit être
mondial gagner de l'argent et investir
or malheureusement Alcatel Lucent a
perdu ce leadership mondial au bénéfice
d'acteurs d'autres pays qui ont eu des
marches plus importantes qui ont investi
qui ont pu prendre des risques parce que
leurs résultat leur permettaiit alors
qu'Alcatel Lucent est dans une position
défensive depuis plus de 15 ans ces
comptes sont dans le rouge ces comptes
sont dans le rouge et quand vous
n'investissez pas ben vous perdez cette
position de leader qui seul permet de
fixer des emplois en Europe alors
aujourd'hui le président de cette
société franco-américaine reconnaît que
le plan social est douloureux hein et
très très très difficile qu'est-ce que
peuvent faire les autorités les
autorités peuvent faire énormément de
choses contrairement ce qu'on croit même
dans une oui oui dans un pays ouvert
dans un pays dont les frontières sont
libres euh un gouvernement à la
responsabilité de la productivité du
pays sur long terme refuser par exemple
ce licentiment massif absolument
pas non la question qu'un gouvernement
doit se poser c'est suis-je en train de
donner à mon pays toutes les chances
pour ces entreprises de gagner de
l'argent la réponse est non avec ce
gouvernement et c'était pas terrible
avant mais avec ce gouvernement c'est
carrément non à partir du moment je veux
dire par là que les 35h oui je sais ça
ne m'a pas échappé et les 35h nous les
avons
encadr libéré nous avons fait le maximum
nous n'avons pas tout fait et
aujourd'hui je suis obligé de constater
que la productivité la compétitivité
française s'est dégradée par rapport non
pas à la Chine mais par rapport tout
simplement à l'Allemagne notre voisin
alcaten Lucent paye globalement et pas
simplement en France parce que c'est une
affaire américaine et internationale
elle paye le fait de d'avoir perdu pied
progressivement de ne pas avoir
reconstitué des marges et une une
entreprise qui ne gagne pas d'argent
c'est un message très simple une
n'assure pas d'avenir à ses salariés
aujourdhui vous dites il faut accepter
ce cette purge l'État ne peut pas faire
ne peut pas faire autrement parce qu' il
ne va pas subventionner alcathel il ne
va pas nationaliser alcathel c'est une
affaire absolument mondiale et il ne
peut pas non plus la diriger parce qu'il
n'a pas les compétences pour le faire il
faut bien savoir que l'État ne sait pas
diriger un groupe électronique
professionnel mondial ce que peut faire
l'état c'est en effet un plan soci
veiller à ce que le plan social soit le
plus parfait possible et surtout pour
l'avenir se donner les moyens d'aider
les entreprises ou plus exactement de
donner aux entreprises des conditions de
réussite le crédit imp pour recherche
est une vraie réussite il faut continuer
de le de de soutenir ces opérations là
et puis je pense aussi une autre une
autre option pour la France c'est nous
avons des points forts et nous avons des
points faibles mettre s'il y a un peu
d'argent public notamment le crédit
impôt recherche le mettre sur les
secteurs où nous sommes forts je pense
l'aéron
le spatial je pense l'énergie l'énergie
nucléaire se donner les moyens d'être
les meilleurs là où sommes déjà forts
estce que on ne peut pas être bon
partout vous reconnaissez quand même les
efforts du gouvernement pour favoriser
la compétitivité des entreprises je ne
les vois pas je ne vois pas on parle du
cice dont on ne sait pas comment il sera
payé et qui va se traduire infin
vraisemblablement par une charge sur la
production c'est-à-dire sur les
entreprises les entreprises depuis euh
18 mois ont supporté je crois enfin une
une addition en milliards d'euros
considérable le gouvernement vient de
renoncer à la taxation de l'excédent
brut d'exploitation tant mieux c'était
une folie absurde qui allait tuer
l'investissement il va doubler un impôt
qu'il a retrouvé à cette occasion donc
mais pourquoi la charge fiscale augmente
parce que le gouvernement n'a pas
relancé le le travail en France la
compétitivité française comme nous ne
gagnons pas de part de marché est
évident qu'on est obligé d'augmenter les
impôts ce que nous ne gagnons pas
l'exportation nous sommes obligés de le
payer par des impôts alors nous parlons
économie oui oui nous parlons économie
Gérard Longuet chacun s'accorde à avoir
en françois Hollande un social-démocrate
bonint même s'il ne s'assume pas
forcément et vous donc je disait avec 16
autres sénateurs vous voyez la France
basculer dans le collectivisme n'est-ce
pas un excès qui rappelle quand même les
critiques de 1981 lors de l'élection de
François mitteron oui alors l'auteur de
de cette de ce communiqué j'en gardo que
je soutiens en l'espèce complètement à
stigmatisé une mesure qui est la
collectivisation du risque sur le
locataire c'est-à-dire que le
gouvernement nous dit c'est très simple
la loi du flot le gouvernement nous dit
c'est très simple les locataires ne
payent pas donc on va faire une
assurance qui sera obligatoire les
propriétaires et les autres locataires
vont payer ça veut dire que
collectivement nous allons propriétaires
et locataires vont se trouver obligés de
payer pour les mauvais locataires que
va-t-il se passer c'est des mauvais
locataires se sentant protégés en disant
bon bah il y aura une assurance je
planterai une ardoise chez mon
propriétaire et je dirai au proprioot et
ben mon vieux allez voir l'assurance
c'est du collectivisme insidieux mais
qui s'applique à une seule mesure en
faitppque une seule mesure l'p je rass
ah bon oui on a peut-être pas tout à
fait compris alors la situation sociale
alimente en tous les cas le Front
national Manuel Val s entrepris un tour
de France des régions où il est en
pointe est-ce que vous le voyez le
ministre de l'intérieur comme un rempart
efficace contre l'extrémisme mais il est
en contre élection totale avec sa
majorité il appartient au gouvernement
de madame toira qui en ce moment même
est en train de multiplier les les
signes extrêmement forts de complaisance
de sollicitude de mensuétude avec les
délinquants comment voulez-vous que ce
gouvernement soit crédible monsieur
valall c'est certainement un homme de
conviction il a son franc parl ça ne me
choque pas mais ça ce n'est pas
rassurant pour autant parce qu'une
action gouvernementale c'est une action
collective et jusqu'à présent lorsqu'il
y a une décision collective elle tombe
dans l'escarcelle de Madame tobira garde
des saut dont la réforme pénale sera
présentée cette semaine don la réforme
pénale sera non seulement présentée mais
sans doute adoptée or c'est une réforme
absurde puisque comme l'a dit
Jean-François Copé elle elle se fonde
sur l'idée que puisqu'il y a pas de
place en prison lesissons les
délinquants dehors mais ça c'est une
idée qui a court aussi parmi vos
collègues um là je les cite également
Gérard longuetin les peines de probation
sont été soutenu par par l'UMP au cén
mais on a le droit d'avoir plusieurs
avis mais globalement si vous voulez le
le le le fait carcéral est un élément de
en tous les cas de allez de retrait d'un
certain nombre deincant de période
active alors que les prisons é des
défaut j'en suis le premier convaincu je
visite celle de mon département entre
l'hygiène la promiscuité la complicité
et parfois le la transmission des des
informations à l'intérieur des prisons
les prisons ne sont pas parfaites mais
donner la certitude de la liberté c'est
l'appel à la délinquence Marine Le Pen
veut attaquer en diffamation ceux qui
qualifient son parti d'extrême droite
est-ce qu'elle nie l'évidence
oui enfin ça
dépend mon sentiment personnel c'est
quand vous avez des
positions quand vous avez des position
extrêm de rupture sur des sujets comme
en effet
l'Europe l'identité française sur
l'autorité sur les acquis sociaux bah
vous êtes extrémiste c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes extrêmement hostile à tout ce
qui fait la France d'aujourd'hui donc
c'est un parti d'extrême droite c'est un
parti de rupture et donc d'extrême
ministme et en particulier sur un sujet
qui qui est au cœur de de l'avenir
français qui est l'euro et la
construction européenne euh Madame Le
Pen j'ai lu un peu son programme ferme
les frontières abandonne l'euro c'est un
extrémisme économique qui va entraîner
d'autres extrémismes parce qu'évidemment
de proche en proche c'est toute la
société qui serait reprise en main par
l'autorité politique si le Fond national
avait des responsabilités ce qui je le
pense profondément n'aura pas lieu le
porte-parole des députés PS Mandon parle
lui d'un Parti national fasciste en
raison bah de ses position sur les
minorités sur les corps intermédiaires
non mais la la référence historique est
c'est un chiffon rouge qui qui qui sert
les intérêts du frond national la gauche
vous l'avez noté Gérard Languet la
gauche appelle à faire barrage contre le
candidat du Front national extrémiste
dimanche prochain à la cantonale de
brigol dans le Var donc la gauche reste
fidèle au front républicain c'est un
geste que vous appréciez non la gauche
elle est elle a dévissé dans l'électorat
populaire elle n'existe plus dans
l'électorat populaire elle en tire les
conséquences soit mais elle ferait mieux
de se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi le Front national existe et en
partie parce que justement les annonces
de Madame tobira ne inquiètent les
Français et les amène à accepter des
positions extrémistes mais cet app c'est
Madame tobira qui fait le Front national
Vals ne l'empêche pas et si les
socialistes veulent nous soutenir j'en
suis très reconnaissant en général ils
ont bénéficié des voix du Front national
pour faire battre des députés P ce fut
mon cas 1997 je m'en souviens donc vous
êtes reconnaissant quand même à cette
attitude
républicaine je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autre choix et je suis très heureux
pour notre candidate quel est ce soutien
car ça lui sera utile car ça lui sera
indispensable ça lui sera le soutien de
la gauche sera indispensable à votre
candidate oui absolument sinon elle ne
peut pas gagner c'est clair la gauche
n'a pas de doute donc apparemment pour
savoir qui est le plus sectaire entre un
une UMP en
l'espèce ça c'est très simple parce que
les UMP sont souriant et sympathique ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas des amis
de Monsieur Mélenchon vous vous avez
mais entre un PS et un Front national
vous vous avez un doute pour savoir qui
est le plus exeur humainement si vous
voulez je ne ferai pas la zoologie
complète de toute la carte politique
française il y a certainement des gens
sympathiques un peu partout je dis
simplement que le Front national
n'apporte rien à notre pays et que le PS
le tire vers le bas et que les deux sont
complices c'estàd que le PS gagne parce
que le Front national existe un/art des
électeurs se dit prêt à voter Front
national aux prochaines élections
municipales Gérard Longuet selon un
sondage LH2 Nouvel Observateur qu'est-ce
que vous ditesv aux sympatisants UMP je
crois qu'ils sont un sur deux à pencher
pour des alliance avec le Front national
dire la seule façon pour Hollande de se
sortir du mauvais pas dans lequel il
engageait notre pays et sa majorité
c'est de jouer avec le frond national et
comme miteran a su le faire en son temps
en 88 enfin dans un passé lointain nous
avons à affirmer nos convictions nos
valeurs à être en tête au premier tour
et de telle sorte que après les
électeurs
auier tour c'est la logique de ce qui
prouve d'ailleurs que l'une des
responsabilités de l'UMP c'est d'abord
de garder tous les siens et d'être
suffisamment sympathique et attractive
pour s'élargir y compris vers le centre
je pense que le centre a une
responsabilité historique si le centre
veut travailler seul il permettra au
Front national d'être au deuxième tour
et il porterait une responsabilité assez
lourde donc je pense que l'un des
problèmes enillera peut-être c'est
qu'est-ce que l'UDI aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que le modem aujourd'hui
séparé il contribue à donner la
perspective d'un deuxième tour PS Front
national vous êtes satisfait du retour
au berkaaille comme l'écrivait Jacques
julard dans Mariane cette semaine de
François Baayou donc François Baayou est
un homme qui compte incistblement il a
sa personnalité il est parfois agaçant
il est souvent imaginatif et généreux en
tous les cas il aime la politique et il
la connaît bien mais vous êtes satisfait
de son nouveau virage sur l'aelle je je
le préfère là qu'ailleurs très bien
allez mais il faut qu'il aille plus loin
encore nous allons évoquer maintenant le
retour de Nicolas sarzi avec Nad puljac
de l'Agence France Presse l'ancien
président est donc libéré du boulet de
l'affire bê encour mais politiquement il
a encore d'autres écueils sur sa route
judiciaire d'abord et puis politique
ensuite ainsi François Fillon qui se dit
aujourd'hui prêt pour l'affrontement
Sophie
normand on le connaissait posé modéré et
rassembleur on le découvre combatif dur
et impétueux depuis plusieurs semaines
François Fillon multiplie les sorties
dernière en date dans le Journal du
Dimanche ancien Premier ministre
s'affranchit et lâche le mot rupture il
a un objectif les primaires de 2016 il
faut qu'il fend de l'armure il faut
qu'il devienne lui-même et et qu'il
prenne un certain nombre de liberté et
cette parole libre c'est ce que les
Français attendent de lui changement de
style mais pour ce proche de Nicolas
Sarkozi la rupture est fondamentale le
premier signal a été donné il y a un
mois François Fillon appelait alors à
voter pour le moins sectaire en cas de
duel psfn il droitisse l'image parce
qu'il pense que notre électorat estant
droitisé ça vaut mieux pour la primaire
si Nicolas Sarkozi revient je pense
qu'il a un sujet c'est que cet électorat
là sera plutôt pour sarcozi et et et son
image autrefois plus centriste plus
modérée lui aurait permis d'avoir un
autre électoral il fait un Paris sur
2016 un Paris qui passe par une
compétition directe ce sont ses mots
avec Nicolas Sarkozi à qui il n'a plus
parler depuis plusieurs mois finit donc
l'image de collaborateur de l'ancien
Président le député de Paris veut se
démarqué de celui qui pour beaucoup de
militants UMP reste considéré comme le
recours providentiel pour 2017 François
Fillon dit se libérer et affirme
travailler sur un programme lui aussi de
vraie rupture une stratégie un peu
décalée pour Jean-Pierre rafarin je ne
conteste ni la légitimité ni la qualité
de franceç Fillon ni les idées
simplement ce que je dis c'est que cette
logique du quinquena qui nous oblige à
être en campagne présidentielle fait
qu'aujourd'hui on tient le discours de
2017 en 2013 et pour les Français
je le dis sérieusement c'est décalé des
Français qui continuent de plébisciter
Nicolas Sarkozi dans les sondages contre
la côte de François Fillon
P voilà nadèj puljac nous rejoint notre
concert de l'Agence France Presse vos
questions à Gérard Longuet nadèj alors
la stratégie d'affrontement ouvert de
François Fillon envers Nicolas Sarkozi
est-ce que c'est la bonne stratégie je
su absolument incapable de de porter un
jugement sur une stratégie
présidentielle n'ayant à titre personnel
jamais été candidat une présidenti vous
êtes un soutien de Monsieur Fillon vous
devez quand même avoir une idée
j'apprécie ses convictions j'apprécie
son comportement j'apprécie son
expérience et j'ai passé dans son
gouvernement sous l'autorité du
Président de la République c'est le cas
du ministre de la défense des moments
parfaits maintenant dans la vie
politique française rafain disait à
l'instant le fait présidentiel semble
tout écrasé or il y a une vie politique
avant 2017 cette vie politique elle est
parlementaire elle est partisane elle
elle est municipale elle sera cantonale
et régionale en 2015 sénatoriale aussi
mais le sujet si vous voulez ça ne me
très franchement comme disait Chirac ça
me fait ça me touche l'une sans faire
bouger l'autre parce que c'est joliment
dit c'est du Chirac dans le texte oui je
sais que c'est du Chirac dans le texte
mais je voudrais quand même revenir à
des choses plus TER à TER franis Fillon
qu'un homme de son âge et son expérience
a envie d'afficher sa personnalité et de
dire je ne suis pas là simplement pour
être un assistant ou un collaborateur
c'est son droit le plus strict et je
pense que sa démarche enrichit la vie
politique transgression même
transgression voilà le mot exact sa
transgression enrichit effectivement on
a beaucoup parlé de transgr vie
politique parce que si vous voulez moi
j'ai une très
grande fidélité sympathie reconnaissance
à Nicolas Sarkozi mais c'est agréable
dans un dans une vie politique d'avoir
plusieurs talents il se trouve que parmi
les talent qui se confirme ou qui émerge
François Fillon en fait partie très
clairement à un niveau d'ambition qui
est
supérieamb vous ne répondez quand même
pas à ma question parce que vous ne
voulez pas répondre à ma question
question très franchement ne me concerne
pas il y a des choses sur l'existence de
Dieu je ne pas
capable dans
deur C mal
entendu je m'engage en politique par
conviction je ne suis pas un homme ni
une femme d'ailleurs j'ai des
convictions libérales républicaines
européennes je suis décentralisateur je
crois l'économie entreprise et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que ces valeurs soient
défendues au à chaque combat et en
particulier au présidentiel qui auront
lieu en 2017 d'accord très bien alors
tout à vous qu aux hommes je les connais
tous et compte tenu de ma longévité
politique je les connais en général
entre 30 et 45 ans donc si vous voulez
il y a peu de chance que le le chemin de
Damas me foutrooit sur la route de
l'Assemblée nationale lequel des deux
entre François fillan et Nicolas Sarkozi
vous semble le plus à même de défendre
vos idées que vous avez rappelé votre
positionnement libéral parce que il
semble que Nicolas Sarkozi se détache de
ce positionnement là d'ailleurs il a
reproché à François Fillon de vouloir se
faire élire en promettant la retraite à
65 ans ou en promettant en français
qu'ils allaient travailler 39h puis 35
programme de l'UMP d'ailleurs de
Monsieur Copé pour reprendre la le titre
de livre de de François Fillon la France
accepte la vérité et la vérité c'est
qu'on travaille pas assez par rapport
aux Allemands qu'on commence trop tard
qu'on s'arrête trop tôt le moins d'heure
par semaine et et que cela est un vrai
problme pour notre compétitivité tout à
l'heure vous nous avez rappelé que vous
avez été ministre justement sous la
présidence de Nicolas Sarkozi ça veut
dire quef ministre de la défense de la
défense comme vous savez
constitutionnellement est en fait
rattaché au président alors le François
Fillon éta le Premier ministre Nicolas
Sarkozi était le président vous les avez
vu fonctionner ensemble tous les deux et
comment c'était l'ambiance c'était
électrique entre eux non non non parce
que si vous voulez François fillan est
quelqu'un qui joue le jeu qu'on lui ass
signe quand il est premier ministre d'un
président de la République il se
comporte comme le premier ministre d'un
président de la République de la
5èe quand il est candidat à exister
propriomotu et sur ça avec son enseigne
et bien il fait ce qu'a fait George
pomido à Rome d'accord alors on plus
anciens on va on va revenir sur monsieur
Sarkozi le nom lieu d'hier c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour l'UMP c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour la justice d'abord
ça prouve que la justice est
indépendante et qu'elle n'a pas céd à
l'acharnement qui qui qui frappait
Nicolas Sarkozi il a quand même les les
attendus des juges qui sont dures qui
sont sévère est-ce qu'ils peuvent jeter
la suspicion sur monsieur Sarkozi les
juges mentionnent dans l'ordonnance de
nonlieu effectivement un comportement
abusif de Nicolas Sarkozi lors de sa ou
ses visites au domicile des bêtes en
cours je je ne sais pas si je n'ai pas
lu ces attendus je dis simplement qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de poursuivre Nicolas SAR
c'est de toute façon il a rien à dire
non lie
c'estour qui etç en familiarité le ma de
qui éit ma depuis 25 ans deille c'est
pas complètement anormal est-ce qu'il
est anormal qu'il a distribué des
enveloppes pendant des années ça vous
pouvez c'est un secret de polyinel c'est
un secret de polychinel Jere qu'un seule
chose c'est qu'il n'en a pas donné au
parti républicain quand j'étais
trésorier parce qu'au moins ça nous
aurait aidé mais à partir du moment ce
n'était pas interdit par la loi pourquoi
ne leuril pas fait alors sur sa page
Facebook hier monsieur Sarko évoqué ceux
qui l' soutenu mais aussi les
responsables politiques alors je lis sa
phrase qui ont participé à cultiver le
soupçon à son égard et les fionistes
dont vous faites partie est-ce qu'ils
doivent se sentir visés pas du tout
alors qui il visaient qui alors de qui
parlait-il vous posa la question et on y
manquera pas quand on l'invitera
n'est-ce pas Michel bien sûr bien sûr il
peut répondre à cette question et à
d'autres dès qu'il le veut posera la
question mais dans dans mon cas
particulier je connais bien la la
justice et je connais bien son
fonctionnement j'ai bénéficié de quatre
non de oui c'est ça de de nonlieux et de
quatre relaxes en correctionnel et en
cour d'appel confirmé donc j'ai je nai
je je saise que des ce qu'est être
soupçonné et être innocent je sais ce
qu'on sent et Nicolas Sarkozi je
l'imagine ressent une immense libération
et je crois que c'est formidable pour
lui et et et si vous voulez la France a
pas tellement de talent qu'on puisse se
priver d'un homme d'énnergie quoi qu'il
fasse même s'il s'occupe d'abord et
avant tout de de de communiquer et de
parler en comme il le fait en conférence
internationaleou il pourrait même faire
plus
mieux tout s vous savez il a beaucoup
d'imagination et je pense qu'il peut
nous surprendre par les responsabilités
qu'il qu'il pourrait envisager d'assumer
pour on moi je je le vois je je pense
que l'Internationale la dimension
européenne la dimension internationale
est naturellement la vocation d'un homme
qui était Président de la République
française et qui a démontrer dans les
crises internationales son aptitude à
agir dans l'action c'est quoi une place
à l'Union EUR é quelque chose comme je
n'ai
pasation manifestement il envisage son
retour sur la scène politique intérieure
Gérard Longuet vous pensez que c'est une
mauvaise piste pour lui c'est une piste
qui est ouverte à tout le monde bien
mais votre
sentiment mon sentiment c'est qu'il a
une vraie dimension internationale et
que c'est un atout pour notre pays qu'il
pourrait mettre au service de la
franceti c'est une gentille façon de
toutexer
201 simplement rappeler qu'entre nous
sommes en 2013 et que 2017 par
définition c'est dans 3 ans et demi mais
tout à fait c'est pour ça d'
question réfléchissons entre nous
Nicolas Sarkozi est suffisamment connu
pour pas avoir besoin de conduire une
campagne de notoriété il il connaît
également on sait qu'il connaît les
problèmes il connaît les problèmes
également donc a-t-il besoin de faire
une campagne de 3 ans et demi pour les
présidentiels la réponse est absolument
non il a besoin en revanche j'en suis
persuadé d'être un homme dans l'action
c'est un homme d'action quels sont les
actions dans les institutions bloquées
de la 5e République il n en a pas chef
de parti oui c'est la seule qui soit
ouverte on n pas l'impression qu' soit
très intéressé par la présidence de
l'UMP penseriez-vous d'un second
quinquen de Nicolas Sarkozi ce serait
une bonne ou une mauvaise idée question
diff constitutionnellement c'est tout à
fait possible et en 2017 il y aura un
choix de candidat et et je participerai
au choix du cand d'accord pour Nicolas
vous pensez que ce serait un choix
opportun selon
vous les deuxent se dire et on le verra
en 2017 bon et en tous les cas s'il
revient on peut imaginer qu'il participe
à une primaire la primaire elle est
actée maintenant hein dans les débats
dans les dans les dans les statuts de
l'UMP lement il doit y avoir une Prim
grand différence siz moi j'avais
beaucoup travaillé avec Charles pascois
sur le thème des primaires dans un passé
récent et la grande différence entre les
États-Unis et la France si vous voulez
c'est que aux États-Unis le le le
président des États-Unis je dirais pas
qu'il sort de l'inconnu mais il n'y a
pas de de cursus sonorome il n'y a il ce
n'est pas prévisible par exemple le
poste de Premier ministre le poste de
chef de parti n'existe pas on va
chercher quelqu'un et je vous rappelle
qu'aux États-Unis également la politique
se fait à coût de millions de dollars
puisque on peut communiquer librement en
achetant des espaces en France c'est
tout à fait différent on chemine
progressivement vers la notoriété on est
reconnu par son expérience la primaire
certes mais la primaire n'est pas sera
jamais en France une découverte ça
peut-être dans certains cas s'il y a une
équivalent
é vousê de dire il n'urait pas besoin
monsieur SAR par je pense non je pense
que la la
vraisemblablement grande prudence mais
je préfère être prudent que péromtoire
vraisemblablement l'opinion française
qui connaît ces hommes politiques
formulera un jugement alors avec un
bémol que vous connaissez bien
d'ailleurs qui est celui de 95 où où
l'opinion semblait baladurienne et
Jacques Chirac a gagné la primaire elle
vous semble quoi aujourd'hui l'opinion
l'opinion de toute façon il faut faire
attention à une réalité simple c'est que
la droite modérée a le devoir absolu de
se mettre d'accord avant la
présidentielle j'évoqué les centristes
mais c'est encore plus vrai et à
forceorie pour le MP donc la mise en
ordre de la candidature est
indispensable parce que le Front
national sinon risque d'être l'arbitre
de la présidentielle et comme en
2002 nous proposer un choix impossible
au deème tour d'accord alors vous nous
parlez beaucoup de la droite modérée
tout à l'heure vous AZ entendu
l'UMP doit être attractive sympathique
pour pour attirer les électeurs du
centre c'est ce que vous disiez à Michel
tout à l'heure quand Monsieur Fillon dit
bah entre un PS et AFN choisissez le
moins sectaire est-ce que ça c'est
sympathique est-ce que c'est attractif
pour les électeurs du centre j'entends
he c'est pas un jugement de valeur je
pour les électeurs du centre mais même
pour les électeurs MP ça peut être en
effet surprenant si on ne connaissait
pas l'histoire même de François Fillon
moi je je viens de la droite et je sais
que François Fillon vient du gaulisme
mais qu'il a été vis-à-vis national très
euh catégorique non non je crois il a
pas dit ça il a dit très exactement que
non non non il a dit je ne veux pas
qu'on m'impose un un prête à penser et
le prête à penser c'est qu'il se il se
reconnaît le droit en fin d'émission en
fin d'émission il arrive parfois que
queon se lâche il en fin d'émission il
s'est reconnu le droit d'évaluer pour
des municipales la qualité des personnes
pour un deuxè tour de municipal
c'est ce que j'ai entendu c'est ce que
j'ai entendu non non mais c'est ce que
j'ai entendu sur ce que vous avez vou
entend non c'est ce que j'ai entendu sur
il s'est dit sur une municipale je ne
veux pas qu'on
m'impose un prête à penser et je dois
reconnaître pour avoir accueilli au
parti républicain madame Yan Pia le nom
vous dit rien cé vous êtes gentil vous
croyez que je suis très jeune mais je
suis pas si jeune que ça la seule femme
élue du Front national
elle l' qué au bout d'un an passé au
parti républain justement et c'était une
femme qui de qualité qui qui s'était qui
s'était trompée sur le sens profond du
Front National et Monsieur bonpar n'est
pas au frond national il a étélu avec
cette étiquette donc à tout pêcheur
miséricorde dernière question oui tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé de brigol mais
je voudrais juste vous poser une
question revenir làdessus Valérie P a
dit que des socialistes et des ver à la
candidate UMP à brtigol à à brigol à
brigol ben c'était pas terrible
finalement cont alors vous nous avez dit
le contraire moi ce que je voudrais
savoir c'est qu'est-ce que vous pensez
alors pourquoi Val nous a dit ça ne me
dites pas demandez luui à elle on lui
demandera quand on l'invitera mais
est-ce que ça vous a surpris partage pas
cet avis moi je pense que si des
électeurs se sont de gauche vert se
rendent compte de leur impuissance et en
tire les leçons ben tant mieux c'est
c'est une leçon de de modestie et
réalise de leur part et vous leur dites
merci par avance et je au nom de la
candidate je je pense que la candidate
les remerciera très bien merci après son
élection on suivra
ça pour vous c'est encore possible alors
qu'elle gagne ça va quand mêmere
difficile he pour lu par que parce que
parce que ça fait 50 % hein quand on
additionneoite quand on additionne le
Front national le candidat d'extrème
droit ça fait 49,4 avec 33 % de
participants oui vous croyez qu'ils vont
se déplacer au deè tour vous
avezz on on va pas regarder dans la
boule de cristal on verra
si depu nous rejoint maintenant et c'est
notamment votre expérience de ministre
que nous allons solliciter maintenant
Gérard longu notamment durant la
présidence mitan il faut le rappeler
bien avant votre titre de ministre de la
Défense pour analyser cette fois le
style Holland puisque question de
l'autorité du chef de l'État revient
régulièrement entre deux quques
ministérieles Jérôme
Rabier monsieur le Président de la
République au pouvoir depuis un an et
demi François Hollande élu sur une image
de rupture avec Nicolas Sarkozi subi
depuis les critique sur son style
présidentiel manque d'autorité voire de
courage pour certains mais pour sa garde
rapproché il faut cesser de le comparer
à son prédécesseur shoter au sarkozisme
il y a à un moment donné il va falloir
que la France se désintoxique de
l'agitation perpétuelle l'agitation
perpétuelle c'est pas de l'autorité
auout il faudrait donc s'habituer à une
autre forme d'autorité plus en douceur
moins médiatique celle de François
Hollande problème c'est bien avec un
discours sécuritaire et d'autorité que
Manuel Vals est devenu le ministre
préféré des Français Vals incarne
personnellement cette autorité et c'est
à travers l'autorité que Vals peut
dégager que Hollande et hos apparaissent
comme n'étant pas assez autoritaire ça
s'est déjà passé il y a une dizaine
d'années et on s'en souvient ça
s'appelait Nicolas Sarkozi face à
Jacques Chirac et et Jean-Pierre affarin
différence notable Jacques Chirac était
alors dans son 2uxe et dernier mandat
alors que François Hollande n'est qu'au
début d'un premier quinquena le chef de
l'État a d'ailleurs déjà su imposer des
choix parfois avec autorité même si les
qui gouvernementaux viennent ternir ses
décisions l'affaire du Mali la manière
dont il a décidé aussi le pacte de
compétitivité la manière dont il a
résisté à la rue sur le maage pour tous
donc on peut pas dire que François
Hollande soit quelqu'un qui manque
d'autorité il y a plus un problème de
charisme une critique qui lui colle à la
peau puisque déjà lorsqu'il dirigeait le
Parti socialiste certains le décrivaient
comme un chef sans volonté de trancher
mais à l'image de ceux qui s'y sont
frottés à cette époque le président de
l'Assemblée nationale reconnaît que sur
la durée François Hollande a toujours su
s'imposer regardez le nombre de
critiques de ce genre qu'il a pu
affronter au moment où il était premier
secrétaire et je crois qu'il a démontré
à plus d'un ce qui était son manque
d'autorité ne confondez pas son sourire
et son autorité la méthode Hollande au
Parti socialiste comme au sommet de
l'État a finalement peu changé l'art de
la synthèse dont certains se sont moqués
est devenu la concertation vantée comme
méthode de gouvernement le président ne
compte pas en dévier même s'il l'a
promis au prochain quoi gouvernemental
il serura tranché voilà per est avec
nous perine bonsoir bonsoir
Michel est-ce que vous êtes de ceux qui
pens qu'il y a une défaillance en
matière d'autorité à la tête de l'État
je crois qu'il y a une grande injustice
à comparer François Hollande et François
mitteran François mitteran est arrivé à
la présidence au terme d'un très long
parcours politique en connaissant des
épreuves invraisemblables dont il avait
créé parfois les les conditions lui-même
et c'était un un combattant couvert de
de de
cicatrices qui avait ét
nont pere non il n'a pas connu les
épreuves que qu'a connu François Miran
je pense pour avoir un homme comme
Valérie giscardestin avait été un
combattant de de volontaire de la
deuxème Guerre mondiale il avait connu
la les républiques difficiles
l'incertitude de politique et il avait
combattu le gaulisme dans des conditions
certes internes mais qui étaient de de
très fortes tension Jacques Chirac avait
joué au contraire le rôle du bon
camarade qui n'était pas nécessairement
dans toutes les circonstances soyez-en
certain mais en revanche il jouait le
rôle du bon camarade il était ressenti
comme tel par nos compatriotes et s'il a
battu s'il a été s'il a battu Édouard
Baladur en 8 15 c'est parce que
justement il avait ce ce préjugé de de
gentillesse de bon amie de bon sens avec
François Hollande justement
entreacolloui avec la différence si vous
voulez c'est que il était vraiment le
patron de son camp alors que François
Hollande donne le sentiment d'être et
vous l'avez dit dans votre reportage
l'homme des synthèses mais qui n'est
patron de personne quel signe d'autorité
vous aimeriez aujourd'hui percevoir de
la SA il y en a qu'une je il y en a
qu'une c'est de garder ou de faire
partir quelqu'un et à condition de pas
taper sur le plus FA faible je je vais
vous raconter pu que
vousou juste une anecdote quand Édouard
Baladur était premier ministre j'étais
ministre d'industrie bon il y a un écho
de presse qui qui ne le convenait pas
quand votre premier ministre vous
appelle à 7h15 du matin parce qu'il est
déjà à son bureau et vous êtes en train
de prendre vos croissants et vous dit
Gérard j'ai l'impression que là-dessus
on est pas d'accord du tout bah ça
s'arrête tout de suite et et ce cette il
y a une aut naturelle dont Hollande ne
jouit pas naturellement il ne faut pas
non plus qu'il surjoue son son son
problème est très difficile il n il est
naturellement normal ça ne porte pas
l'autorité et s'il surjoue l'autorité il
fera sourire alors de réflexion trouve
VO do faire partir aujourd'hui du oui
oui alors de réflexion par Rapp il
coexiste il fait coexister Val et tobira
c'est un nonsens complet il fait
coexister Arnaud mbourg qui aime
l'industrie je suis pas toujours
d'accord avec lui et Madame du flot ou
ou n'importe quel écolo qui est
anti-industriel c'est un manque non
c'est un manque de de choix on a
l'impression Politi un membre de cap
politique l'autorité procède du moment
où vous prenez un risque parce que vous
voulez tenir un cap et jusqu'à présent
aujourd'hui il a préféré éviter les
risques et abandonner le cap donc c'est
un manque de ligne politique claire qui
s'impose à tous et notamment aux
personnalitutorité procède pour un chef
qu'il soit de guerre d'entreprise ou de
politique de la const dans le cap et de
la confiance profonde dans la validité
de ce cap donne pas sentim et que
devient le premier ministre dans ce cas
de figure c'est un
autre du qu aussi le quena le quinena a
tué matigon soyons très clair quelle est
la seule à quoi servait un premier
ministre à gagner les élections
législatives intermédiaires ou à être
viré pour gagner les élections
législatives intermédiaire il y a plus
d'élection législative intermédiaire la
seule élection qui compte au soir du deè
tour des présid présidentielle c'est le
premier tour des présidentielles
suivantes et entre-temps le Premier
ministre sauf s'il gère une majorité
mais quelle est la majorité qui a envie
de se déliter en 5 ans aucune elle est
élue dans le siage de la présidentielle
elle est solidaire le Premier ministre
ser pas grand-chose autre grand absent
du débat politique en ce moment c'est le
parti socialiste quelle place peut jouer
le parti majoritaire dans cette
configuration VZ pour avoir été dans un
parti majoritaire avec un président
régant que c'était vrai à l'UDF de
giscar ou avec l'UMP
extraordinairement difficile on pensait
que les socialistes auraient une culture
de la liberté à travers cette tradition
des courants de temps en temps ça bouge
un petit peu à l'Assemblée en terme de
proposition mais quand on vote c'est
toujours le même vote on verra bien
d'ailleurs sur les retraites le le
gouvernement n'a de majorité qu'avec le
Parti socialiste à l'Assemblée nationale
on verra bien s'il y a une défaillance à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste et je
suis persuadé qu'il n'y en aura pas non
euh je voulais vous oui socialiste
n'existe pas parce que quand vous n'êtes
pas une source de pouvoir ou une source
d'incertitude vous n'existez pas euh
Michel Sapin le disait dans le sujet
qu'on vient de voir la France est encore
shootée au sarkozisme il faut se
désintoxiquer de l'agitation perpétuelle
dis tout récemment il le disait la
semaine dernière est-ce que vous pensez
que Michel Sapin n'est pas in agité il
est calmos hein un peu plomplom on sait
d'ailleurs pas ce qu'il fait sur les
chiffres trava c'est pas lui enfin c'est
lui le patron excusez-moi c'est le
gouvernement qui donne les chiffres du
chômage c'est pas le c'est pas pour
l'emploi mais est-ce que vous vous
pensez comme Michel Sapin donc que la
France est en demande d'apaisement
elle est en demande de courage
tranquille c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose le courage tranquille expquez-nous
les nuance ah ben c'est très simple
l'apaisement si ça consiste à ne rien
faire vous différez les problèmes et ils
seront plus graves après le courage
tranquille ça consiste à dire désolé les
enfants ce qu'on a faire n'est pas drôle
mais on va le faire parce queun fois que
c'est fait on aura plus à le faire c'est
les déficits c'est la productivité c'est
le temps de travail des dépenses
sociales ce sont des mesures d'autorité
pour que les professeurs soient
respectés pour que les sergentss de
ville soient respectés pour que on a
beaucoup progressé en France il faut pas
être moi je suis pas du tout décliniste
regardez on a réussi dans en matière de
transport public grâce à des lois
Sarkozi à ne plus avoir de grèves
inutiles et on peut travailler un
certain nombre de sujets sans mettre la
France en paralysie la France mûit il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin beaucoup
beaucoup plus loin est-ce que Sarkozi
lui il avait pêché par excès
d'activisme à l'heure du de l'inventaire
du bilan hein l'UMP avec la convention
qui va avoir lieu moi je je si je n'ai
qu'un seul grief à faire à l'encontre de
de Nicolas Sarkozi c'est qu'il n'a il
n'a pas euh
m les Français en face de leur
responsabilité à certains moment il
aurait dû dire à sa majorité à ses
ministres à ses soutiens ou à d'autres
partenaires au patronat au syndicat mais
attendez faites-le faites-le montrez ce
que vous savez faire Nicolas est un
homme généreux et et quand il voit qu'il
y a un problème il veut le régler
lui-même de temps en temps il faut
savoir dire aux autres ben allez-y
faites le boulot vous verrez bien ce que
vous on verra bien ce que vous êtes
capable de faire mais là encore on
revient au kakena qui a accentué he le
côté présidentialisation du du régime
avec avec un septéna un président
immitérant l'a fait souvent pouvait
prendre du recul et et se détaché y
compris de son camp y compris de son
gouvernement d'ailleurs vous
souvenez-vous de la phrase de Fabius lui
c'est lui et moi c'est moi et ça allait
loin et finalement ça permettait de
respirer aujourd'hui entre avec le
quinena il y a plus de moment de
respiration on sait qu'on on prend pour
5 ans de Hollande on a été condamné à 5
ans et euh et voilà et on peut rien
faire d'autre si franç Hollande manque
d'autorité naturelle est-ce qu'il fait
un bon chef de guerre au point de vue
militaire je dois reconnaître qu'il a
pris la bonne décision au Mali celle que
l'étatmajor avait préparé que nous
aurions pris si nous n'avions pas été en
situation 1 de campagne électorale et si
la menace avait été aussi forte mais il
l'a fait et je suis reconnaissant
François hande qui était aussi très en
pointe sur le dossier
alors là c'était je pense je pense qu'il
y a eu une petite erreur diplomatique
c'est que les Américains nous ont traité
comme des chiens je je veux dire par là
que pas de notre faute alors si un peu
quand même parce que si vous voulez il
faut savoir décision de Barack Obama
qu'il faut mettre en Cuse d' il faut oui
mais il faut savoir avec qui on part
faire la guerre parce que si vous vous
partez faire la guerre avec quelqu'un
dont vous pouvez penser raisonnablement
qui n'a pas envie de la faire vous
passez pour une bille et c'est un petit
peu ce qui s'est passé Obama aimait les
français tant que les Russes lui
claquaient la porteoné le au moment où
les Russes ont entreouvert la porte il a
Laé tomber les Français il faut s'en
souvenir il aurait fallu être plus
prudent ou plus exactement comme l'a dit
François Fillon et je partage totalement
ce
sentiment faire ce que la France a
toujours fait parler aux Russes et aux
Américains justement François Fillon lui
il a parlé aux Russes il a parlé à
Poutine en Russie est-ce que vous avez
été choqué que l'ancien Premier ministre
que vous soutenez vous nous l'avez
rappelé au cours de cette émission et
bien apporte son soutien à un dirigeant
occidental engagé dans un bras de fer
avec notre pays
la il n'est pas dirigeant un homme
politique aujourd'hui il participe à bon
en
grosadir on l'appelant Vladimir non je
Cance la Russie nous a beaucoup aidé et
la Russie n'est pas notre adversaire il
se trouve que nous avons un différent
d'analyse sur la Syrie mais ce n'est
qu'un différent d'analyse sur la Syrie
la Russie est un grand pays continental
dont une partie est très clairement
européenne et nous ne pouvons pas
rejeter la Russie il faut avec elle en
l'espèce suite été un mois avant ou un
mois après c'était mieux c'était mieux
donc il a été un peu trop loinie
d'accord il y a 2 millions de réfugiés
syrien aujourd'hui est-ce que la France
doit en prendre sa part alors que
François annoncé qu'il
all rapport en 2014 ou je pense que nous
ne sommes pas en mesure de régler la
guerre entre les chiites et les sunites
qui depuis le détroit d'ormuse jusqu'au
Nord au Sud Liban oppose ces ces deux
grandes cultures une petite question sur
les Romes pour terminer Gérard longuer
Vals a dit il les Romes n'ont pas
vocation à rester en France vous
partagez ce point de vue ils n'ont pas
de volonté d'intégration il a il y a un
vrai problème oui c'est vrai il y a un
vrai problème la France est un pays de
sédentaire onù le est individualiste et
et les cultures communautaires mobiles
sont assez largement incompatibles avec
notre vie quotidienne pourquoi parce
qu'il faut scalariser les enfants parce
que il faut accepter l'exogamie et non
pas l'andogamie intégral et il faut
accepter que chaque individu soit libre
il n'appartienent ni à un clan ni à une
tribu ni à un Pater Familias despotique
toute l'histoire de l'humanisme
français avant la Révolution et bien
après ça été d'afficher la primauté de
l'individu et dans ce vieux pays paysan
la sédentarisation les Romes c'est
exactement le contraire c'est le
collectif le clanique le tribal et la
mobilité on a beaucoup de mal à se
comprendre il y a des réussites il y a
des réussites pas de Rome d'ailleurs
parce que ça sont les nouvelles
générations mais il y a des des vieilles
familles d'origine manouche entre
guillemets jeangorenart enfin qui
existent en France depuis longtemps qu'
se sont intégrés est pour autant les
stigmatiser ceux qui ne veulent pas
accepter nos principes de de de de vie
commune qui sont je le répète l'exogamie
c'est-à-dire on se marie avec les gens
que l'on connaît et pas simplement avec
le clan et on est fixe et on vit dans la
vie locale et on respecte la vie locale
parce que quand quand vous êtes de
passage sa les gens qui sont de passage
que ce soit d'ailleurs des des
militaires en permission ou des lycéens
français dans le sud de l'Angleterre
quand ils sont en séjour scolaire ils se
tiennent parfois un petit peu légers
hein et bien quand vous êtes une unité
constituée pour avoir été élu local je
peux vous dire que les passages laissent
parfois des séquelles donc vous
considérez comme Manuel Vals que les
Romes n'ont pas capacité ou vol il faut
pas globaliser mais le fait est qu'il y
a des systèmes à l'intérieur qui sont
qui ne veulent pas qui ne choisissent
pas l'intégration merci d'avoir été avec
nous cette semaine merci perine la
semaine prochaine notre invité vous
l'entendrez et vous l'écouterz avec
attention sera François Baayou bonsoir
et très
vite